the FBI wants to know if Ray's played a
role in the murder of a black man by a
white student on the campus of one of
the nation's largest universities police
say 23 year-old Richard Collins the
third was stabbed and killed by Sean
Urbanski while waiting for an uber at
the University of Maryland Jan Crawford
is in College Park at the campus bus
stop where Collins was stabbed John good
morning
well good morning Nora Sean Urbanski is
being held without bond for the stabbing
that took the life of that promising
Bowie State University student Richard
Collins while he and two friends were
waiting here for that uber on Saturday
night police say the stabbing was
completely unprovoked and they may have
information that suggests it could have
been a hate crime Sean Urbanski with a
knife stabbed Richard Wilbur Collins and
killed him police in Maryland say they
have reason to believe 22 year-old
murder suspect Sean Christopher Urbanski
a student at the University of Maryland
may have used race as a motivator in the
murder of Richard Collins we're here to
evaluate that as an ongoing concern with
respect to whether or not this was a
hate crime the FBI has been called in to
help with the investigation which
centers around a racially charged
Facebook page for the group all right
nation Urbanski
was a member it shows extreme bias
against women Latinos members of the
Jewish faith and especially
african-americans Saturday morning's
murder shocked Maryland's campus as the
community gathered for commencement
weekend a Bowie State University student
who lost his life in a senseless and
unprovoked assault Richard Collins was
preparing to receive his own diploma
this week from nearby Bowie State
University and serve his country he
completed his ROTC training and was
commissioned last Thursday as a second
lieutenant in the US Army Haight has no
place in America
hate has no place on a college campus
now as of this morning that all right
Facebook page appears to have been taken
down Collins was said to have joined the
Intelligence Division of the US Army and
set to walk across the stage here on
this campus tomorrow to get his college
degree Gale very sad sad story thank you
very much Jann